h.r 3884 as the member designated by ms
lee
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that ms lee will vote yes
on h.r 3884 as the member designated by
mr kennedy pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that mr kennedy
will vote
yes on h.r 3884
and as the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that ms mang will
vote yes
on h.r 3884
so
is
mr kennedy goes
[Applause]
this pancreas
channel
very
yeah
so
oh
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from california rise
madam speaker as the member designated
by representative brian higgins of new
york
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that mr higgins will vote i
on h.r 3884.
my proxy
yes
oh
um
um
every day
let's see
uh
this is
okay
peace
[Music]
something okay
um
perfect
so
there's
what's up
for what purpose does the young woman
from florida rise
madam speaker as the member designated
by mr hastings of florida pursuant to
hres 965. i inform the house and mr
hastings
will vote yay on h.r 3884 and madam
speaker is the member designated by ms
mukhersel powell of florida pursuant to
hres 965.
i informed the house that ms mukhersel
powell will also vote yay on
h.r 3884 and madam speaker has the
member designated
by mr payne of new jersey i informed the
house that mr payne pursuant to hrs 965
i informed the house that mr payne will
also vote yay
on h.r 3884.
my proxy
mr payne that votes on my proxy
does any member wish
thank you
let's see what's up
you see
are you ready
foreign
this is
next
oh
so
let's do that
wow
foreign
what
yes
hey
okay you
thank you
yes
so
uh
so
left
uh
on this vote the yeas are 228 the nays
are 164.
the bill is passed without objection the
motion to reconsider
is laid on the table
gradually
hello
tricks
all right
so
foreign
gentleman from louisiana seek
recognition
speaker i asked unanimous consent to
speak out of order for the purpose of
inquiring to the majority leader the
schedule for next week
without objection thanks and mr speaker
i also ask unanimous consent to revise
and extend my remarks with that
objection
with that be happy to yield to my friend
the gentleman
from maryland the majority leader of the
house
i thank the gentleman for yielding mr
speaker on monday
the house will meet at 12 p.m for
legislative business
members are advised that votes are
expected as early as 2
p.m i want to repeat that we're going in
at 12.
votes can be as early as 2 p.m this is
unusual for
the first day of the week i have advised
and urged members to stay here this
weekend most of them
i've talked to are because clearly we
are trying to get
two critical pieces of legislation done
which we will speak to i think
in a little bit on tuesday and wednesday
the house will meet at 10 a.m for
morning hour debate
and 12 p.m for legislative business on
thursday the house will meet at 9 00 a.m
for legislative business i want to
advise members
that we still have to
pass an omnibus and we have to pass a
covert 19 relief bill
and we will not adjourn the congress
until such time as we can accomplish
those two objectives
i was hopeful that we would accomplish
those objectives
by next thursday unfortunately things
are not moving
as rapidly as i think they ought to i'd
like them to but as they ought to be
moving
so that members need to be advised that
they need to keep their schedules very
very flexible
until such time as we pass both of those
pieces of legislation
we will in addition consider several
bills under suspension of the rules
the complete list of suspensions will be
announced by the close of business today
i want to say something further on
suspensions
somebody said oh well we're not passing
important bills that's not accurate
uh somehow when we have agreement
it's not looked at as important on
suspensions
simply mean we have an agreement uh
between the parties that we can pass
those bills because they're
bipartisan and the overwhelming majority
of members agree on them
so we are passing bills that are good
bills but not controversial
and that's a good thing we will consider
several bills on the suspensions as i
said the complete list will be available
at the close of business today
the house will consider the fiscal year
21
national defense authorization act
conference report
i am very pleased that we have a
bipartisan bicameral agreement on ndaa
and look forward to overwhelmingly
passing both chambers next week
and if necessary overriding a threatened
veto by president trump
this is a critically important bill to
pass it always passes
and i am hopeful that we will come
together
on this bill it was a tough conference
but a good conference
and the result i think can be supported
by both sides of the aisle
signed obviously by the senate
republican chairman
and our chairman here in the house as
members know the current
continuing resolution expires on
december 11th
therefore the authority for spending
to keep government running and will
expire on the
11th the appropriate committee
appropriations committee is
hard at work on reaching an agreement on
an omnibus and i hope to bring
that to the floor as early as possible
i'm hopeful that will be next week uh
frankly i
had a discussion with senator mcconnell
i've told there is no agreement
that we can not make on the 11th
that will be easier to make on the 18th
which is the end of the following week
i would urge members however to ensure
that
they are available for the week of the
14th
if we have not completed our business by
next week
the house may also consider additional
legislation to address the coronavirus
pandemic as i've already said
the house has passed two different
heroes bills
mr speaker we passed a bill on may 15th
six months ago to deal with this
extraordinary crisis
uh placing millions of americans
at risk causing deep
emotional and physical distress
and a challenge not only to their health
but also
their psychological welfare and to
educating our children and keeping our
schools
safe and providing the resources
necessary that if we can get children
back in school which i think all of us
want to do
that we can accomplish that objective
the house has
also passed on october 1
some two months ago a
2.2 trillion dollar bill that was not
taken up by the senate
the senate has passed no legislation
since may 15th they did not consider our
bill
uh either either time either the heroes
one bill or the heroes two it's
unfortunate
unfortunate in my view that senate
republicans have failed to act
even if they didn't act on what we
wanted
to do i'm pleased that the speaker and
senate majority leader spoke yesterday
i've spoken to him three times this week
and i hope that we can get an agreement
the house stands ready to act
next week lastly
uh as everybody understands when you get
to the end of a
session we don't contemplate everything
that might be on the agenda
so that other pieces of legislation may
be on the agenda
uh next week or the week thereafter
again i want to reiterate i am very
hopeful
that we could get this business done by
next week the reason i scheduled mr
speaker
the 11th uh as the cr day
is because i wanted to make sure we
could get members home
the cobit crisis the pandemic
is has exploded
members ought to be not aggregating here
on the house floor or aggregating in
washington they ought to be home
and if we got out on the 11th
i want to get through on the 10th so we
can send a bill to the house
i mean to the senate however if we left
on the 11th it will be 14 days before
christmas
and therefore if members leaving
washington had to
quarantine themselves they would have
sufficient time to do so so that they
could be with their families
on christmas day um but i i i would hope
that everyone on the appropriations
committee uh
the leadership myself included would
feel the urgency
of passing this needed legislation
and i thank the gentleman for yielding
thank the gentleman and a few of the
items
relating to legislation that i want to
bring up with the gentleman but before
that
i did want to mention that it's my
understanding that
the floor director for the majority
leader miss shawanza goff uh last thing
i'd want to do was embarrass her here on
the house floor but
it's my understanding she may be leaving
and uh
if i can just first say a vicious rumor
that has been spread abroad in the
country
and she i'll be happy to yield time to
her if she'd like to deny that rumor but
uh while that may create some issues i
would uh
i would like to say that uh this is the
last time that we do this
colloquy before the end of this year
it's been a true pleasure to work with
shawanza golf my whole staff has enjoyed
working with her
and especially on those areas where we
agree the cares act
and usmca come to mind as recent major
accomplishments that this legislative
body has done
together republicans and democrats and
uh and she
i know has been that conduit who works
with with our staff on the republican
side and uh we
we've considered it a true joy to work
with her
uh she doesn't schedule every bill i ask
her to schedule but uh i'll blame that
on
the majority leader not on schwanza but
uh i uh
if i can in all seriousness say that uh
it's truly been a treat and a joy and
she's one of the people that makes
this place work when it does work you
know we can always talk about the things
that we
would like to achieve that we can't but
there are many important things we
achieve
like those pieces of legislation i
talked about many others that don't get
that same kind of attention but they
wouldn't happen
without the work and the great
leadership that
schwanz has demonstrated here she will
be missed here
uh but uh i just wanted to mention that
and i know the gentleman feels
probably even stronger because she's
worked for you i think for the whole
time i've been in leadership but i think
uh going back to maybe 2008
and i would yield back till the
gentleman yield i would yield to the
gentleman um
i may get into this next week and i'm
hopeful the gentleman is right that we
don't have a colloquy next week
that we will have completed our business
as i've been talking about
but uh i i have been blessed
the house has been blessed the country
has been blessed
by schwannzeghoff's leadership on this
floor on my behalf and on the majority's
behalf
working closely with the minority
and i know that schwanza would want me
to say that she looks forward to the
same kind of cooperation in her new job
that she's gotten in her old job
and if the gentleman wants to are sure
of that i'll yield to it
i'll i'll i'll give this assurance to
the majority leader that
if you're looking for replacement i'll
be happy to provide recommendations and
even participate in the interview
process if that
if that would be helpful to the
gentleman from america the gentleman is
most generous
i i think the generosity probably ends
there with today's colloquy um
i uh but maybe we i'm sure we'll have
that opportunity next week to have a
longer conversation but truly do want to
pass that on to uh to shawanza and uh
and not just on behalf of myself on
behalf of the the minority leader mr
mccarthy his staff
as well as mine and all of us in
leadership who get to work with her
uh with that i do want to mention on the
schedule next week one of the items
that i know we've worked on together and
talked about that i believe the
gentleman is scheduled
for next week is s 578 which is the als
disability
insurance access act something that
we've worked on a number of these items
for people with als the steve gleason
act
was one of those items we worked on a
few years ago passed to help people with
als it has been a tremendous tremendous
benefit
uh to people struggling with als uh
steve gleason
is a constituent and a dear friend
somebody who we've worked with
uh on many things he received earlier
this year seems like years ago but just
january of this
year was the recipient of the
congressional gold
gold medal and uh and deservedly so
but he and i were communicating earlier
this week about this legislation which
i'm a co-sponsor of and i just want to
thank the gentleman
for scheduling that for the floor next
week one of those areas
as you were talking about earlier it
might not get a lot of attention but
an issue that both republicans and
democrats have worked on to help people
with als who right now
under current law even after the
diagnosis with als as we know is just a
devastating diagnosis
uh have to wait five months to get the
normal benefits
that they are entitled to and in time is
very very critical
to people with als and this uh
eliminates that
five-month gap uh where they would have
to act
one one of those additional occasions
where it takes an act of congress to fix
this
and the senate acted and quickly now the
house will be acting
to address this deficiency that needs to
be fixed
i think you will see both sides come
together with a very large vote but i
want to thank
the gentleman for scheduling that for
the floor next week and i would yield if
he had anything to add on that
well i was pleased to schedule this
obviously as you know it's
past the senate the other day and
hopefully we will pass it on suspension
next week and it will be sent to the
president hopefully the president will
sign it
obviously als is a just a terrible
terrible
disease and a disease that acts very
very quickly
which meant that there's a premium on
the government's
response to assisting people with als
be quick as well and as we know what
this bill does it
provides for an acceleration for people
who are suffering from an afflicted with
als to get
assistance so hopefully the house will
pass and we'll send to the president
and i appreciate the gentleman's
co-sponsorship of the bill
thank the gentleman for yielding uh this
relates to the schedule next week as
well as
the schedule we've had this week uh i
want to bring up a piece of legislation
that we've talked about
here at this colloquy and in other
venues for months now and that is
the bill by congressman chap at h.r 8265
which is
the paycheck protection program
extension act uh
we've seen over these last few months
our small businesses have struggled
tremendously some industries have done
better during this pandemic
uh where they've seen increased sales
for various reasons but we've
mostly seen and heard from so many of
those businesses and industries that
have been devastated
some harder than others but so many
devastated to the point
of bankruptcy uh daily we see stories of
businesses that close their doors
for good uh in the state of new york
alone it was reported
that a third of all small businesses a
third
will never open again and when we
came together to do the cares act to
pass
that lifeline to so many small
businesses saved probably
50 million jobs in america say millions
of small businesses
but it expired and when it expired
we learned a lot more about where our
economy was at that time when we passed
it it was at the very beginning of the
pandemic
we now saw over those months which
businesses were doing better which
weren't
and came back in september with a piece
of legislation that would free up money
that's
not going to have to be borrowed money
that's actually sitting in that account
frozen 137 billion dollars
that we already appropriated but the
program expired so it can't be used
anymore unless we change the law so
we're not talking about creating a new
program we're talking about
going back to a program that was maybe
one of the most successful things that
we've done
to help people in need not just those
small businesses but the millions 50
plus million
uh people whose livelihoods depend on
those jobs
and the bill was brought forward had a
lot of bipartisan
interest but for various reasons hasn't
been scheduled on this
house floor and there were reports that
maybe it was tied to
waiting on the election or whatever
other things in fact the speaker the
house just today made a comment
that one of the reasons that bill a
certain relief package bill wasn't
brought to the house floor is because
she was waiting on quote a new president
i hope that was a quote that was made
out of context or maybe needs to be
revised
but there are millions of people that
are literally
facing the elimination of their
livelihoods
and we have a bill that if it was put on
the floor
today yesterday september
when we first had this conversation
there would be hundreds of thousands of
businesses still open today that are now
bankrupt that will never open again
every day we wait more businesses don't
reopen
clearly we are negotiating to try to get
an agreement on bigger issues
we're not there we weren't there last
month we weren't there the month before
the senate's tried to take up votes on
things it wasn't the republicans it was
the democrats that blocked those bills
from coming up
this by the way was one of those in the
package that would have been voted on by
the senate if not
for senate democrats blocking even the
debate
on the senate floor so they never had
that debate
on this floor this just today we saw a
bill to legalize marijuana
you saw items in there where it would
give
additional money to people in the
marijuana industry
now this is something that congress i'm
sure will continue to debate
but there's a pandemic where today
we have businesses that are shutting
their doors tomorrow businesses will go
bankrupt forever
small businesses and we can help them
not with a new program that we need to
negotiate the details over but something
we already did that was so highly
successful
that we have a track record to show what
it can do our small banks
local community banks were part of that
process and are ready to go
again again we don't need to reinvent
the wheel here this is an existing
program that has got
existing remaining money but the program
is frozen and expired
and this bill just renews it and could
pass
on the suspension calendar and still
hasn't
been brought up and while we're
negotiating other things
why not release this hostage and let
this bill
pass could have been done today wasn't a
lack of time
when we're debating legalizing marijuana
instead of saving small
businesses that is a misplaced priority
of this congress we should have come
together
months ago september 16th it was
introduced september 17th i brought it
up to the majority leader
at this colloquy the following week
brought it up again and then we filed a
discharge petition
you had i think 23 democrats signed a
letter saying that they would sign that
discharge petition
if we didn't get a bipartisan agreement
recognizing that the heroes act is not a
bipartisan agreement unfortunately
not one of those members who signed the
letter saying that they would sign the
discharge have signed the discharge
talk is cheap around here livelihoods
are being lost
businesses are shuttering for good
why can't this bill be scheduled for the
floor while we work on the other things
that we're not in agreement on
this is something we're going to
agreement on but it won't be scheduled
for the floor
maybe maybe we can get an agreement to
schedule that monday
when we're coming in at two o'clock to
vote on other items
this would be something that would get
400 plus votes
if it was just scheduled and i would
yield to the gentleman
i thank the gentleman for his
observations um
he is right we're for this
we're also for making sure that children
have food on their tables
we're also supportive of making sure
that
education facilities have the money to
keep their
venues safe and to keep education
flowing
we're also for making sure that child
care is available to parents
who can go back to work
when and if their children go back to
school
we're also for having critical money for
testing
and tracing and yes for delivering the
vaccination
and yes uh we're for that and we're also
for states and localities who that are
hemorrhaging revenue
have the resources uh to continue to be
on the front line of fighting the battle
against covet 19.
uh and we're money we are also
for resources not only to
have created the vaccine which much of
which
almost all of which is being funded by
the federal government we are also for
making sure we can deliver
that vaccine and have a vaccination
as well as having a vaccine
we are uh four
very strongly the extraordinary number
of helping the extraordinary number of
unemployed
who are unemployment insurance and who
at the end of this
month are going to find it goes away
and we're for having an additional
enhancement of that
unemployment insurance which so many uh
economists will tell you
from the cares bill was absolutely
essential to keep the
economy afloat and the fact that we have
kept the economy afloat is shown by the
apparently the stock market thinks we're
okay but the millions and millions and
millions of families who are in deep
distress
are not okay i am appalled
by the fact that we have not acted we've
acted twice
you say it wasn't partisan that's true
you chose not to vote for it
it wasn't much different than the cares
bill which you did vote for
but apparently shortly after we passed
the uh
heroes bill your leader mr mccarthy said
let's wait and see what happens
and senator mcconnell said let the
states go bankrupt
well they're on that road and
we've seen what happened by waiting
we have thousands of our fellow citizens
dying every week thousands
now over 260 000 americans
millions afflicted so i tell my friend
uh mr speaker that
we care about ppp and we took care of it
in both bills we passed now it wasn't a
question that they were
partisan or not partisan they weren't
taken up
in the united states senate we passed
them
we're not taken up yes the
senate leader offered a bill that
every economist with whom i've talked
said was
not substantive enough not
sufficient resources to stop the
hemorrhaging
and to help fight covet 19.
so i tell my friend we're for that bill
what we're not for is forgetting
the kids the families the hospital
workers
the researchers the states
the localities we're not forgetting them
and we believe that if we pass one part
of a multi-faceted response to cobit 19
and the
implication for our economy that will
not be what our economy
nor our people need so we would ask
you to talk to the senate or to offer
your own bill
offer your own bill offer your own bill
that deals with all of those millions of
people that i just referenced
that are in deep
deep distress uh
because we need to deal with the small
business and then we do we need to deal
with the unemployed
and and we knew we have a lot of things
expiring on december 31st
ppp your bill does not deal with any of
that
uh we need to deal with all of it uh
we ought to do it and that ought to be
mr shabbat's bill ought to be a part
of that and it will be because we're
committed to that
but we're also committed to not
forgetting all of those
people and elements that i mentioned
uh i i want to help the airlines
and hopefully that will be in any deal
that we can
come to i want to help the restaurants
these are people who are through no
fault of their own
devastated so i tell my friend
he is right but only partially so
he is right that we ought to be helping
the small business but i don't think
there's a small
businessman in america that would say
let the nutrition issue go
as we see lines of cars
and lines of people getting food boxes
so they can put food on their table for
their kids and themselves
people who would never ever expect in
their lives to be in a food line
i think the small business would say
take care of them
i think the small businessman would say
you know i haven't been able to pay
taxes and i know the state's
still operating uh hospitals is still
operating uh
fixing the roads it's still hiring
police and fire
it's hiring nurses in public hospitals
they need help too
and we're all in this together so that's
uh
my response to the gentleman uh mr
speaker
uh we want to have a comprehensive bill
that will deal with a comprehensive
threat to our economy and to the health
of our people
and to the welfare of our people we
think that's the responsible thing to do
so
i'm hopeful that we can get an agreement
uh
in in the near term and when i say the
near term by next week
uh and i've been talking to senator
mcconnell towards that end
uh the speaker is talking to senator
mcconnell towards that end
senators are working on a an effort to
get that done
i'm hopeful they're successful speaker
and
mr schumer said it was a place that they
could
negotiate from which means we're closer
than we have been and i hope it gets
done
i yield my time let me remind the
gentleman that in the cares act
we addressed many of those issues that
the gentleman already brought up
starting with the states
in fact i don't know of a single state
in this country
who has spent all the money we sent them
educational
opportunities for schools to reopen
safely and educate kids
are being denied in some places but not
in others but it's not from a lack of
money
there's not a single school system i've
heard from who says
my state where we sent them the money
and by the way they've still
got millions and in some cases billions
of those dollars
sitting in their account idle that can
be used today
to safely reopen schools if the state
chooses not to do it
or if the school system chooses not to
do it that's on them but they're denying
those kids opportunities
and we're seeing report after report
scientific studies
the american academy of pediatrics
talking about the damage
that's being done to our young children
by being denied
the opportunity to go back to school in
classroom
and learn it's devastating to those kids
suicides are up opioid abuse is up
because of
all of these things and it's the small
businesses who are paying the biggest
price and so if you look people
that are getting unemployment insurance
at the state level we did enhanced
uninsurance for p
for a period of time and in most cases
we were paying people more money not to
work than they were making before
they lost their job what they ask me
is not that they want to stay on
unemployment they want to go back to
work they want their business to be
alive
when they go back to work but if a small
business closes
for good the cost to us is going to be
dramatically higher
if we can right now throw that lifeline
again to those businesses not with a new
program
not with things that we don't agree on
like 900 billion dollars to bail out
failed states which is the
the heroes act we already spent hundreds
of billions of dollars that we gave to
states and like i said
i think every single state still has
some of that money left some have
billions of dollars
of that money left so the idea that
we're going to hold up relief to small
businesses
who are closing every day hundreds of
thousands
a third of every small business in the
state of new york are gone for good
how many more need to die before this
problem is recognized by this congress
so those states are sitting on money and
the gentleman wants to hold up their
relief for the small businesses to give
another 900 billion
to bail out states not for the covet
damage but for the problems they had
before
that was what the heroes act
disagreement was about
we agreed on giving states money they
still have some of that money
and it can be used to reopen schools
safely still today
what is not there right now is really
for those small
businesses and so when you look at all
of these different things the vaccine
they're not waiting on approving a
vaccine based on more money coming in we
put money in the cares act
and president trump spent it effectively
on operation warp speed
to get us to a point now where we have
two not one but two
major pfizer moderna ready to go fda is
about to approve
two different vaccines and it's being
mass produced today we're not waiting on
money to mass produce it
the defense department is actually
involved in helping
distribute it airlines have already been
contracted to get it out
some need to be air conditioned more
than others all that's put in place
if we need more money we'll come
together and get more money but a
vaccine is not waiting on us to send
them more money
we need to get it out we need the fda to
follow their process which they're doing
they're the gold standard in the world
for approving vaccines
and it's unheard of in the history of
mankind for a virus that we didn't even
know of
until a year and two days ago in the
world to now be on the brink of not one
but
two fda approved vaccines that's
happening because of what we did
coming together with the cares act and
then president trump's operation warp
speed
so these aren't items that are waiting
on our relief
what is waiting is relief for small
businesses now the heroes act again
it was a partisan exercise not because
it was mostly like the cares act
it was very different from the cares act
in the heroes act
there are billions of dollars in that
bill to give checks to people here
illegally
that wasn't part of any agreement wasn't
in the cares act
that's new policy that's not going to be
signed into law
and if you want to negotiate and hold
small businesses hostage on that
we may never get relief for small
businesses
but that was one of the items in the
heroes act where we had no agreement
but the areas where we had agreement can
we at least agree
to pass the things we have agreement on
and what did we have more agreement on
than anything is
the ppp proven to be so successful
that literally i every day we hear from
small businesses who say they wouldn't
be alive today
if not for the ppp but we also hear from
small businesses
every day who are about to close as some
states
are talking about shutting their whole
state down again their whole state down
again we know that's going to lead to
businesses that will never come back
and we have a bill ready to go that
would get massive bipartisan support
without a new dime of money money
sitting and frozen in account
that would help those small businesses
the criteria is you have to have at
least 25
loss so your small businesses that are
doing well today
and again we know there are some that
are doing better today than they were a
year ago but we also
know some that are about to close for
good and we can help them
not with new policy that we're not in
agreement on
that's where the negotiations are
continuing to go back and forth on
but if there's something we all agree on
do we really need to hold that hostage
when that means
that many of those businesses will never
come back
this isn't something we could have done
this in september it was brought up in
september it's not a new item
how many thousands of businesses died
from the day that that bill was
introduced
to today and will die again by between
now and monday
it can be put on the schedule monday
it's not going to stop the negotiations
on the other things
there are other things that we're both
in agreement on that aren't part of that
bill
bring that as a standalone let's bring
each of those items
that we're not in agreement on but the
idea that we hold everything hostage to
things that aren't going to happen
hundreds of billions to failed states
giving checks to people that aren't here
illegally is that really a priority is
that really the things we're getting
called on every day
the folks that are on unemployment want
to be able to go back to their job and
if the company is dead
and gone there will be nothing to go
back to
and so we're working on so many items
that we're in agreement on we've given
money
to our health experts to continue to
focus on the virus to continue
to get the vaccine and we may have
another two could be four vaccines
by the end of this year that's what we
all ought to applaud
because of what we did when we came
together but here's an area where we
already came together
and it was so successful that that money
now
is frozen and those businesses that did
well are still doing well the ones that
aren't
will or will not be alive in a month
from now based on whether or not we
confront this
it's not new policy it's something we
already agreed on and something we
already celebrated as a success
let's do that one more time while we
negotiate on the things we're in
disagreement with
i would just suggest that and yield to
the gentleman well i thank the gentleman
for suggesting that
i didn't hear him talking about the
children who are
having trouble getting food on their
tables
every morning and every evening i didn't
hear him talking about the unemployed
12 million american workers who are
going to run out of unemployment as of
the end of this month
i didn't hear about him i did hear him
talk about mr speaker
the failed states
let me tell you maryland's not a failed
state
and our governor is a republican his
name is hogan
his father served in this body
he along with mr cuomo the governor of
new york
said the states meaning all the states
need a
substantial assistance where they're
going to have to make
substantial cuts and in my state we have
made cuts
and we're a wealthy state we've made
cuts
which have undermined the state's
ability to respond
as robustly as they need to do to covert
19.
now the president wants to talk about
failed states what it really means is
blue states
mr speaker that's what he means
large states like new york large states
like california but
by the way florida and texas are in the
same position
now texas has a greater surplus
but failed states
is a fake news item mr speaker
what we should do is come together and
have an agreement
now we can pass something here and we
did pass something here
the republicans chose to join us mr
speaker on the first three bills
one was a 8.3 billion dollar bill
responding to 1.2 trillion or 2.2
trillion
that the president asked for in other
words four times as much as the
president
asked for now in terms of what we've
done
that seems like small potatoes a lot of
money
but it was clear that the
administration's response to this
crisis was woefully inadequate
represented by that first bill that they
sent to us knowing full well that it
would not even come close to meeting the
needs
well so we increased it about 400
percent
and then we negotiated the speaker
negotiated with mr mnuchin and came up
with
two additional bills that were passed in
a bipartisan fashion and very frankly
the president told us this was about to
go away
not to worry it's going to go away go go
away tomorrow maybe
or next week it's going to go away when
the weather gets warm and mr fauci dr
fauci
said no mr president that won't happen
and so essentially the president
dismissed
uh mr fauci and dr fauci is a principal
advisor
thankfully mr biden president-elect
biden is going to bring him back
as the principal advisor one of the
great experts in the world
on vaccines and on infectious
diseases
so i'm somewhat frustrated that
we focus on one facet
but i will tell you if those 12 million
people become unemployed without
additional
assistance they won't have any money to
spend on small businesses
if those states don't have an ability to
operate
properly that will hurt small businesses
uh if the transportation system uh
falter
it'll hurt small businesses but my point
is
mr speaker that we are
you know a pluribus unum out of many one
we are a nation reliant upon one another
and the
the uh harm to one results in the harm
to the other and therefore we believe
that there ought to be a comprehensive
piece of legislation as there was
overwhelmingly supported but the
republicans after cares
and when we passed the heroes
act in may passed it on may 15
they thought everything was hunky-dory
and they walked away
mr mcconnell said the state's going to
go bankrupt
think of what that would have had the
consequence that would have had and yes
they we gave them some money under cares
nobody when we voted on cares thought we
would be where we are today
nobody except dr fauci
and some other experts scientists
medical personnel said
look this thing's going to come back
because that's that that's what happens
with these pandemics they have original
insult
assault then they come back and they
came back with a vengeance
and people are losing their lives and
the failure to
pass a comprehensive bill we agree
we want to help these small businesses
and heroes
one help small businesses heroes two
you didn't vote for those you said they
were partisan
i'm not sure what was partisan about
them they were no more partisan than the
cares that was partisan the difference
was
uh very frankly mr speaker the
republicans decided they're going to
vote for cares and then they decided
we've done enough and we've been
twisting in the wind now for six months
since we passed heroes
i don't want to make a speculation of
how many hundreds of thousands or tens
of thousands of lives maybe have
been saved and we passed here as one
or we've acted much sooner out of the
administration
but uh i'm hopeful we can get rid of all
this
who struck john you did it i did it who
did it uh
and come to grips in the next
seven days maybe 14 days
but seven days there's no reason why we
can't come to an agreement
there's a bipartisan
group in the united states senate
republicans and democrats have come up
with a bill
908 billion dollars now that's a lot of
money
but what they try to do is deal with all
of the issues that i've raised
and they do maybe not as much as i think
we ought to do maybe not
as specifically targeted as i think but
it is a basis
for agreement and i hope the senate
passes it i hope they pass it next week
and send it over to us and i guarantee
you when they send it over to us
we'll uh we'll we'll act on it we won't
leave it sit
as heroes one and heroes two have sat in
the senate
for six months or two and a half months
we won't let us sit why because the
country
is at risk our people are at risk our
children are at risk our families are at
risk
and as you so correctly point out mr
speaker
points out that our business is at risk
he's absolutely right and we need to act
but if we only act on small businesses
and we don't take care of the other
problems
the small businesses ultimately will not
be able to survive
either we're in this together
we do not have a policy on this side of
the aisle saying
you're on your own children you're on
your own
unemployed you're on your own states
localities municipalities small towns
small counties
you're on your own that's not our policy
we're in this together and we want to
help all of those
in distress so i i don't know that i'll
have anything more to say on this
particular item
but i am appreciative of mr chabot's
bill
i hope that his bill is included and i
hope that we can pass something next
week
to help all of those in deep distress
that would be good for our country it's
the right thing to do it's the moral
thing to do
and i hope we do it and i will
facilitate it when we get to an
agreement
i thank you gentlemen and and i thank
the gentleman too
you know in terms of our children we
know
sending them back to school safely the
protocols are out there
child nutrition programs are
administered in our schools
that's not happening because the kids
are in those systems where they're not
safely reopened those kids aren't able
to get to school
the general yield on that point i
absolutely was
i don't know about your school system
but my school system
is still providing for meals for kids
either as a pickup
at the school or delivery at some site
so because that is a critical problem
but they need money to do that
and we know that uh food banks are
stretched
and we need to deal with that program
that's my point we need it's not just
small business it's that nutrition
program
but i just wanted to clarify that in my
school districts we are delivering uh
meals notwithstanding the fact that
schools are shut down and let me say
something else just there's another side
three of my counties have a majority if
not unanimous
unanimous county commissioners
who are all republican
they have all voted to keep the school
systems
virtual as have my other counties
i represent five counties essentially
are parts thereof
they've all voted hearing from parents
and teachers
and perhaps some students they're
they're all virtual
they'll need as much money to get to
continue virtuality
as they will to get kids back in school
they need extra resources to do that
and the 908 billion dollar bill that's
[Music]
agreed upon and or not proposed
by bipartisan groups has money in that
bill
for those programs i yield but those
schools
already have access to the 150 billion
we already sent the states that they
haven't even already spent
if i gave you money to do something you
haven't even used all that money you
can't use that as an excuse for not
doing it and saying i'm waiting for you
to give me more money
when you still have money remaining and
i agree with the gentleman on the school
lunch program
the the thing is there is we don't
give a supplement to schools in normal
times these are not normal times but in
normal times
schools feed kids at lunch with the
existing budgets they have they don't
wait for us to send extra money
to them to feed the kids if they're not
educating the kids in the classroom
they're still taking that money i
haven't seen them rebate the money
to those families in those communities
so what are they doing with that money
and so if there's money if you bring the
kids back and educate them safely in the
classroom which the protocols
allow for in any community high risk low
risk if you've got
a high outbreak there's different ways
to handle each community
cdc has given that guidelines academy of
pediatrics have given the
guidelines some school systems just
chosen not to follow them
and then to leave the kids at home and
but they're
still taking the money if there's never
been a better argument
for school choice in letting parents
choose if one school system is willing
to educate your kids safely and others
not
why shouldn't you be able to take that
money and send your kid to the place
that's willing to do it
safely for you so it's not a question of
the money
it's a question of the will to do it but
when we talk about
those businesses and what was in the
cares act and what wasn't the cares act
was not the hero's act
i think the gentleman knows some of the
differences i'll tell the gentleman a
few of the differences
what is in the heroes like that's not in
the cares act that we all voted for
was letting thousands an unknown number
of thousands of
criminals out of prison i've never
gotten a straight answer on how many
thousands of criminals would be let out
of prison
or why that even needs to be in a
coveted relief package
but that's in the heroes act which is
not in the cares act and we are
completely in disagreement
on that why it hasn't been dropped out
who knows but that's a choice the
majority made
again sending direct checks billions of
dollars in direct checks
to people that are here illegally was
not in the cares act it is in the heroes
act
if we wanted to make it bipartisan drop
those things out but they won't they
haven't been dropped out by the majority
and here we have a program that we agree
on but in terms of the small businesses
the small businesses are dying on the
vine
because some states are giving mixed
signals
changing rules going backward forward in
states like california they're saying
you can operate as a liquor store
as a strip club but not as a church even
the supreme court stepped in and said
that's ludicrous and you can't keep
doing it
but then you go to new york and you go
to so many of these states where they're
saying
oh for safety protocols you got to shut
down
you can't go to a restaurant and then
you see the governor of the state
at a restaurant without a mask but you
can't go
you see mayors and communities telling
businesses they can't stay open
or it's not safe to have thanksgiving
with your family and you find out
they're flying to other states to have
thanksgiving with their family
so this blatant hypocrisy by some of
these leaders who are telling you
that you've got to live your life one
way and they're living their lives a
different way
and hiding behind protocols that don't
exist that's driving people nuts
the businesses are dying because of it
but the trust in government gets
depleted in those places because they're
watching it it's not isolated i wish it
was just once or twice
which was never going on but it's over
and over again
yesterday and today another story comes
out of a local leader or governor
telling you you can't do something and
they're doing it
they didn't think they were going to get
caught doing it my god that's got to end
the hypocrisy has to end and let's get
back to saying things that make sense
working with the protocols working with
the experts and the scientists
but don't use a scientist selectively
and say something that's not really true
and you yourself know it's not true
because you're doing it
that's what some of those folks are
doing it's driving people nuts and it's
driving their businesses
under they will never come back those
families that are struggling the kids
that are going to have trouble eating
are having that trouble because the
businesses that their families work for
are being bankrupted by
crazy radical policies that have to end
we can help them in the short term we
ought to help them in the short term
some of the stuff i mentioned that we're
not in agreement on ought to get dropped
out
but in the meantime don't hold them
hostage let's bring those things that we
agree
on to the floor and save the businesses
that we can
because every day we don't more will
never come back
i would yield it the gentleman had
anything else well i just want to say
you know
this business about illegals getting
money let me just give you an example
you have a husband and a wife and three
children living in an apartment
the husband does not have authorization
to be here
and what the bill provided that the
gentleman talks about is making sure we
feed those children
even though somebody that's illegal is
living in the household
what they would uh have done is nobody
in that household got help
it's just a difference of perspective
uh and i get it but let me tell you
something
what you can't get away from
is mr speaker they have not passed a
bill through the united states and
why because it would require compromise
because you can't you don't have the
votes mr speaker but in the republican
party to pass a bill without compromise
so they have sent us no bill now mr
mcconnell can say all he wants
well we need 60 votes and they won't
give us 60 votes he's right
and he won't compromise
yours
[Music]
afternoon everyone
eric let's go first to the data for
today
today we're reporting
one hundred fourteen new cases that is
our highest number
in over a week and our fourth highest
ever our seven day average of reported
cases is now
eight thousand one hundred sixty five so
this is above
our last seven day average by about two
thousand
hospital admissions uh we're reporting
392.
our seven day average is 388. so it's
about the same
today's the third highest day four
deaths
reported at 1 29.
uh again we will point out that these
are not deaths that have occurred today
but ones that have occurred in the
recent days and that we find out about
them in the last 24 hours
our seven day average for deaths
reported is 77.
for now go to dr bruce vanderhoff our
chief medical officer at the health
department
bruce thank you for joining us he's
going to explain
new guidelines for quarantining after
exposure to someone with
cogan19 dr vanderhoff
thank you governor martining after we've
been exposed
to covet 19 is very important
it's very important for helping to
control the spread of this virus which
as we know is
raging for our communities the
quarantine only works
when we actually stick with it knowing
this
and knowing how hard it is to quarantine
for 14 days
the centers for disease control and
prevention has been carefully
merging data that and our growing
confidence
in testing has allowed them to offer two
new
options for quarantining that will be
reasonable
for many ohioans a 10-day option
that does not require testing provided
there are no symptoms
and a seven-day option with a negative
test again
provided there are no symptoms we ask
people to quarantine
that is to stay in their homes after
they've had close contact
with someone who is code of 19 to help
prevent further spread of the disease
because as we know it can be carried and
transmitted
by people even if they never show
symptoms
now i want to be clear staying at home
for 14 days after contact is still the
safest way
to limit the possible spread of covet 19
and we continue to recommend this for
people who
might be in settings in which coping 19
is at risk of spreading extensively
but for others with no symptoms the
10-day
or seven-day period may be appropriate
based on
circumstances or guidance from their
local health department
this may for example be a reasonable
option for many
in a classroom setting where distancing
and masking
are being consistently applied
but in every case whether quarantine for
10 days
or 14 or 7 maintaining
a physical distance of at least 60
wearing a mask when around others are
vitally important
keep an eye out for any symptoms for the
full
14-day period regardless of which option
you are participating in and if you
become sick
or test positive for program 19 well
then you need to stay home
and self-isolate and that means staying
at home
and in a separate room from others
now i can't emphasize enough
how important it is to comply with
quarantine guidance
whenever we've had a potential cov19
exposure
that's why these enhanced quarantine
guidelines are
so important they strengthen our
quarantine guidance
at a critical time in this pandemic by
reducing the burden of quarantine
to improve compliance i want to
reiterate
we understand that quarantine can be
difficult
it can be difficult financially socially
and for mental health reasons
but there is no question that it can
help us reduce the transmission
of this disease when you quarantine
you are protecting your community and
fighting alongside
all highlands to reduce the threat of
covet 19
to our lives into our livelihoods
dr vanderhoff thank you very much um
so in in summary uh this is guidance
from cdc this is now guidance from the
state health department
which goes out to the local local health
departments
and summarize again the
ultimate objective in making this
change what what does cdc hope to
accomplish what does the state health
department hope to accomplish
thank you governor both the cdc and the
state of health and state health
department have recognized
how burdensome that 14-day quarantine
period is for so many
and now we have much more scientific
evidence that we can rely upon that says
well for many people in the state
ten days without a test for seven days
with the test
is going to do a very good job and
because it's
easier to comply with it's going to be
a better outcome more people are going
to be able to stick
with it and therefore we're now offering
that
alongside the cdc as an option for most
ohioans
so one hope would be more people likely
to comply more
people likely to do this that's right
the harder the hill is to climb the
fewer people are going to do it
okay we're trying to we're trying to
lower that hill
all right very good
uh let's turn to to vaccines uh we've
been working with the uh federal
government
on this i had a conversation a couple
hours ago with
with vice president uh about this
and we continue to learn more and
this continues to be fine-tuned and this
will be a work in progress
uh this is not something that we're
gonna set it
and it's just gonna go um it's
gonna be continued to be fine-tuned but
let me repeat
what um
the main objectives are i think these
are the
same objectives we have as the federal
government has and i think it's a
kind of universal objectives uh one is
to save lives
uh to cover the most vulnerable people
as quickly as we can
people who are in a situation where
uh they're more likely to get it and if
they do get it
or more likely not to have good outcomes
the second is to slow the spread of the
virus
and third objective
one more certainly is to make sure that
our health care workers
those people who are on the front line
risking their lives
and those people who we rely on not just
for help with covet
patients but with others uh that they
are able to do their jobs
and that we can do everything that we
can to keep them
safe so as we look at
um the objectives uh we're starting
we'll be starting we hope uh the middle
of this month
in in phase one a um
the priorities that we have set are
consistent
with the priorities that have been given
by the cdc
and i want to go through these um in
just
a general description there may
certainly be different
groups that have been left out but i'm
trying to give you all an understanding
of how this is going to
work
as we begin phase one of the vaccine
distribution we hope that is around
december 15th
uh the following are the priorities
um and these are priorities not in order
they are all the pro all the priorities
um that we will be working
to get the vaccine out to just as
quickly as we can
health care workers and personnel who
are involved in the care of coba 19
patients
read again healthcare workers and
personnel who are involved in the care
of covid
19 patients
ems responders
it's a second group then we come to
a series that i'm going to read to you
of different groups but they really all
come under
this definition and that is that we will
prioritize
vulnerable individuals who live together
in close
proximity and those who care for them
vulnerable individuals who live together
in close proximity
and those who care for them these are
the ones that we have found
these are the ones who we have found to
be the most
vulnerable this would include
residents and staff at nursing homes
residents and staff at assisted living
facilities patients and staff
at state psychiatric hospitals
people with intellectual disabilities
those with mental illness
who live in group homes or centers
and staff at those locations
residents and staff at our two homes for
ohio veterans
so these would be examples
of individuals who will be in group 1a
now we are still waiting uh for
confirmation
um firm confirmation
about what will be sent out in the month
of december
um so we can give you what we believe
these numbers are
and i will tell you what has been
confirmed and what has not been
confirmed
uh but the federal government has made
clear
we will not know for sure what these
numbers are
until we are notified in that week
a few days before we get them we will
get a number
uh and we will know that those those are
in fact
coming it is our understanding
again this is subject to change subject
to shipment um
and we're just trying to provide the
fifa ohio the best information we can
at this point it is subject to some to
change
um pfizer uh on just
honor about if this is approved if this
is all approved
we would anticipate around december 15th
there will be a shipment that comes that
comes out
on that shipment 9750 will go to our
hospitals uh hospitals this will be the
the vaccine that's pre-positioned
um in that shipment you will have 88
725 and that will go
uh to walgreens and cvs to go
to congregate care settings basically in
that first phase of the nursing homes
on december 22nd
we have confirmation of 201 000
from moderna
that will go to uh hospitals
98 hospitals have been signed up
108 health departments hospitals will
obviously work
at vaccinating those who are dealing
with
coping patients health departments
will distribute this to people like ems
they will vaccinate people who are ems
home health care workers for example
and those there would be more examples
but those will go to
as i said to hospitals and health
departments
um on that same day
we have a tentative number a tentative
number
for pfizer that we're seeking some
confirmation on but that number
is a hundred and twenty three thousand
that number is a hundred and twenty
three thousand in december twenty second
uh those you know will continue to go
then
through walgreen and cvs and those will
go
directly they will be vaccinating people
in nursing homes and staff
going to next
date a few days later it will be another
148
we believe coming from pfizer 140 000
and 89 from moderna
so that's what the month looks like
again the
the second and third shipment from
pfizer has not been confirmed we've got
those
amounts tentative but they have not been
at least at this moment confirmed
let me now go to dr
joe gestaldo asking him to
to join us and really talk about
vaccines
why they're important to our work to
eradicate
the virus he's ohio health's medical
director for infectious diseases
medical director of quality and safety
for riverside methodist hospital
doctor thank you very much for being
with us thank you governor dewine
as you know in ohio we remain in a world
war
against a ruthless enemy the coronavirus
causing coven 19.
thus far we have a few weapons we know
that mitigation strategies like wearing
a mask
and limiting your exposure to people
outside of your household
[Music]
to have another major weapon against
defeating this virus
vaccines having an effective vaccine
and vaccination program will be the
first
major step in getting us back to a
pre-covered way of life
preliminary data from both the pfizer
and modernity vaccine suggests that the
vaccines are about
95 percent effective what does that mean
it means that receiving a vaccine will
prevent
people from getting ill it means
receiving a vaccine
will keep people out of the hospital if
it means receiving a vaccine
will save lives i'd like to make a few
comments
about the information we know about the
two vaccine candidates from
pfizer and moderna collectively
both trials prioritize safety
in the highest scientific testing
methods together
both studies have enrolled about 75
000 people from diverse populations
on december 10th pfizer will have their
data reviewed
at the fda by a group of independent
non-government employed scientists
physicians
vaccinologists and other top experts in
the field
the data is going to be reviewed with a
fine-tooth comb
no stone will be left unturned
next after a hopel fda approval
it then goes to another group of
independent experts and scientists
at the cdc's advisory committee on
immunization practices
for review and vaccine recommendations
both review meetings at the fda and cdc
are open to the public
in addition at the cdc meeting major
medical societies will have
representation at the table
for review and discussion of the data
after a transparent fda approval and cdc
recommendation
a vaccine will become available for
americans to receive
as a person of science as an infectious
disease physician and a formal
pharmacist
i have the utmost confidence in the
outlined review
process when a covenant vaccine
is fda approved and cdc recommended
i will be rolling up my sleeve sometime
hopefully in the near future
i will recommend this vaccine to my
parents to my family my friends
and to most importantly my patients
doctor thank you very much for giving us
a description of kind of how this
process works um i know
some people have said uh gee this
process was quick this happened faster
you know should that worry us is there
anything about that that
should worry us and why is it fast why
hasn't been able to be faster
that's a great question governor dewine
so back in the spring the federal
government introduced
operation warp speed as coming up with a
more efficient way
to get a vaccine out there knowing that
we are in a pandemic
what i could tell you is the way the
studies are done
for approval of these vaccines is the
exact same way
that we have done it with previous
vaccines
we're doing it in a more efficient way
that does not
compromise any of the safety
in addition to that the review processes
that i outlined
through independent groups within the
fda and the cdc
are completely the same way we have done
it for years
by two independent groups of experts in
their fields
both of these open reviews at the fda
and cdc are open to the public for me
it's going to be must-see television i
will be listening to those
i'm going to be looking at all of the
details of the study
okay thank you very much
we appreciate it doctor thanks for
coming on and uh helping us understand
and i'm sure that
the news is going to be filled with this
over the next
week or so and people are going to have
the opportunity to turn their tv on and
watch some of this and
you said actually these are these are
public meetings is that right
that's correct governor dewine both the
fda and cdc's meetings for review
are open to the public and again i will
be watching them
i think it's very important for people
to understand the science
and the safety of the vaccines yes
vaccines will help save lives but
we have to have a vaccination program
people have to choose to be vaccinated
i will say this i'm almost giddy about
having vaccines because
i've been talking about coba now for
almost a year
and i want to talk about other things
and infectious diseases
and having a vaccine be accepted is the
first big step we have to get us to hurt
immunity
in a pre-covered way of life
thank you doctor
as you look at this and based on what
you have read
what you have heard um
side effects from this if i if i if i
take this someone takes it
what kind of side effects would they
expect
thank you governor dewine that's a good
question so keep in mind
uh all the information we have is
preliminary data and it's going to be
reviewed like i said with a fine
tooth comb at the fda and cdc
what's being reported so far is people
may have a sore arm or they may have a
headache
what's important for people to realize
is that when you get a vaccine
we want your immune system to become
stimulated
so you develop immunity to the vaccine
so it's not going to be uncommon for
people to feel
off kilter for 24 hours they may have a
headache they may have fatigue
that's not a toxicity that's your body's
way
of responding to your injection and
developing immunity and protection to
this virus
doctor thank you dr stahldell thank you
for
doing this i'm sure you're going to keep
us informed uh if you see anything
um we'll have you back anything you want
to tell us
thank you governor dewine thank you
doctor appreciate it very very much
we're ready to go to questions governor
first question today is from john london
at wlwt in cincinnati
john governor there are those who who
say you've shown remarkable restraint
uh this fall and there are others who
believe you've not acted forcefully
enough
the spring lockdown flattens curve this
fall
surge is getting worse and clearly
there's a percentage of ohioans ignoring
requests to wear masks and not
gather would you clearly lay out to the
state right now what you are willing and
not willing to do
as we move through december and the
winter months
well there's good news and there's bad
news
uh the good news is we have more people
in retail settings
we know because we're counting them we
know we have more people
who are wearing masks and it's it's
throughout the state of ohio
um in the last survey that we did i
haven't got it from yesterday but we
were at about 91
that is a marked improvement we also
think that we're seeing
we saw over thanksgiving a slow down
not huge but a slow down from the
previous thanksgiving
as far as people's movements and that
comes from
data that anybody can look up on the
internet we saw the same thing
in regard to the friday after
thanksgiving
but thanksgiving did occur and you know
it could be
that the cases that we're seeing today
um
you know we may be starting to see those
cases
you know it's probably going to see it
more in the next few days as we as we go
out
we're only you know now eight days away
um you know seven days away from that
friday so
we could be seeing that continue that
spike
up even further if you look at the cases
today
not not certainly not good um
you know what we would hope is we would
see a plateau we're not really seeing a
plateau yet
and then we really need it to go down
look we're having discussions uh i was
on the phone with infectious disease
doctors as i i told you all
the other night we're consulting other
experts
we're consulting i'm talking to
speaker and senate president right after
this press conference i'm talking to
other members of the legislature
so we are in a very very
you know tenuous dangerous situation and
what i think everyone should be able to
agree on
is that we cannot let uh our hospitals
get to the point where health care is is
dramatically
threatened um so we are
not going in the right direction we
think some of the things that we've done
the curfew
that additional mass wearing the
inspection of
retail we think these things have helped
but they've not clearly john they have
not helped enough
and we're going to have to do more and
we're
we're in discussions now trying to get
the best advice best experts but
we are not we're going to have to do
more we don't have any choice
next question is from john reed at
gongwer news service
good afternoon governor john um is there
any priority for people who might be
a caregiver for a loved one who's
vulnerable and getting the vaccine
maybe someone taking care of an older
parent something like that
yeah i'm going to i'm going to go dr
vanderhoff
i don't know whether we're still on
there or not
you want to take that so thank you it's
a very good question
and it really points to some of the
subsequent phases
of uh the the tiering of this vaccine
distribution
uh this first tier is really targeted to
the people who
every day are facing the highest
exposure and